puede que el suministro de northstring
uno Este suspendido por mantenimiento
debido a una fuga de petróleo pero el
gas natural ruso sigue llegando a Europa
a través de Ucrania el flujo aumentó
ligeramente En comparación con el
viernes pero no lo suficiente como para
compensar el gas que debería haber sido
bombeado a través de uno y no está claro
cuando volverá a funcionar el gasoducto
del Báltico en un comunicado en su canal
de telegrama gas promo ofreció una
actualización sobre el estado de las
reparaciones o la falta de ellas ya que
solo pueden realizarse en talleres
especialmente habilitados
de reparación de acuerdo con el contrato
actual se están detectando averías Solo
que no hay ningún lugar donde hacer la
reparación
supuestamente hay una fuga de aceite
cree que nada de esto justifica la
suspensión total del suministro también
desmintieron haber sido llamados para
realizar trabajos de mantenimiento estas
fugas no suelen afectar el
funcionamiento de una turbina y pueden
sellarse in situ es un procedimiento
rutinario dentro del ámbito de los
trabajos de mantenimiento en lo que
muchos expertos califican de represalia
por su apoyo Ucrania Rusia ha acortado
gradualmente el suministro de gasa
Europa a través del gasoducto en los
últimos meses encendiendo los temores en
occidente de una escasez invernal no
obstante el comisario económico de la
Unión Europea afirma que el bloque está
preparado para cualquier escenario
un paso más hacia el corte de los
suministros
sería una violación de los contratos
todos esperan que eso no suceda si
sucede es Claro que habrá consecuencias
Pero también es Claro que nos hemos
estado preparando durante meses para
este riesgo
antes de esta última ronda de
mantenimiento ya había cortado el
suministro a sólo el 20% de la capacidad
del gaso